are we talking about the joint work with
ellet itai
niv yuval and nathan
now listen bob go to new york and they
want to meet up
we all know that it might be a
challenging task to find each other
without a gps
one solution to the problem is that
if alice and bob scan the entire skyline
and search for the statue of liberty
then they can transmit their location
relative to the statue
and then they can compute the relative
location between one another
the problems with this with this
solution is that
a notable object such as the statue of
liberty is not always present in our map
and more often if we do have such an
object
finding it takes a linear time
so we search for a general and efficient
method to communicate relative locations
for this we introduce the concept of
locality preserving action for shifts
or lphs in short
we say that the function h from n bits
to the integers
is a d delta lphs
if
h can be computed by reading
d bits from the input
and if the probability of a random
strings x
that
h of x does not equal
to 1 plus
h of x shifted by 1
is smaller than delta
so in the example below if the h of
alice's input
equals to 9
then we want it with high probability
that
h of bob's input to be 8
because bob's input is alice's input
shifted by 1.
we may think as the h of a string
as the location of the distinguished
object inside this string
because as we shift our string
the value of h
should shift with it except for small
probability
so the old point is to have a good
trade-off between d and delta
we want both d the number of queries to
be small
and we also want delta to be small
as we will see later we cannot hope that
delta to be zero unless
d is large
so we seek for a
good
dependence between d and delta
there are a few details or variants to
our lphs definition
first we consider the average case lphs
definition that is
we wanted that for a random input string
x
that the probability that the shifting
property do not all to be small
however we could insist that for every
input string x
that
that the probability that the shifting
property to not hold on
on our random lphs
to be small
however in the paper we show that these
two definitions
except for highly periodic
inputs is the same
so in this talk we will use the average
case definition
for convenience
also we did not exactly specify how our
shifts are looking
we may use cyclic shifts of our input
and we may also use acyclic shifts that
is
and as i click shifts we chop one bit
from one side of the
of the input and insert a brand new
random
bit in the other side of the input
again in the paper we show that these
two definitions are usually the same
but there are a few differences and in
this talk i'm going to assume the i
cyclic shifts
moreover for two-dimensional
applications of lphs we need a
two-dimensional lphs
that is
we need a function h that receives
a two-dimensional input and returns a
vector of two integers
we again want that this h will return a
distinguished
location
inside our input
and so we want that usually
h of x
and h of x shifted up by 1
to differ by
by the vector 0 1
and we want that usually
the difference between h of x and h of x
shifted right
we want the difference to usually be
zero one
so this is the definition of two
dimensional lphs and we showed the
different constructions for both kinds
of
of lphs definitions
later in the talk we'll show a good
construction for an lphs
for now i want to present several
applications of such a good construction
the first application is algorithmic
we construct the nearest neighbor data
structure for the shift metric in this
problem we're given several input
strings in advance
and in query time we're given an a new
string and we need to find the closest
string in our
database that is
closest with respect to the shift metric
other applications are to graphic and
include location sensitive encryption
that is
we can encrypt a
a message so that only people who are
physically close to us will be able to
decrypt
and we also show an application to
homomorphic secret sharing
well
well
this technique
gives state-of-the-art solution in terms
of communication of several problems
and we show how a good k-dimensional
lphs
can give even less communication in such
problems
the goal in our first application is to
construct a data structure as follow
we are given m input strings which we
should pre-process and insert into a
data structure
then when we are given a query string
queue
then we should find
one of the strings that we were given
earlier
that minimizes the shift distance
between q and this string we output
so how do we use the concept of lphs to
construct such a data structure
and for this we define the notion of
locality sensitive hashing for shift
distance
this object is a family of hash
functions
which satisfy that for every input
strings x and y
the probability that we have a collision
between the ashes of x and y
with respect to a random mesh function
from our family
then this probability of collision is
high if x and y
are they close in our shift distance
and this probability is low if x and y
are are not closing in our metric
so how do we construct
such a family of hash functions
if we have an lphs
so recall that lphs gives us
a distinguished location inside our
string
and if two strings are closed in in the
shift metric
then
by the definition of lphs
it is likely that they share the same
distinguished location
so
if instead of
outputting the location and we output
the
the feature that lies inside the
location of this distinguished place
then we get we get such a family of a
hash functions
and using a general idea due to undone
and indeed
and this gives us the data structure
we described
now for a second application
recall that alice and bob are in new
york
and suppose that alice wants to encrypt
the message so that only a
physically close friends will be able to
decrypt
so she encrypts a message using
information that is around them
we want the jasmine which is a friend
which is physically close to alice will
be able to decrypt this message
using an information that surrounds her
while bob which is a friend but which is
not close to alice
will not be able to
to decrypt this message
how can we use lphs in order to
construct such location sensitive
encryption
so we call that lphs allows us to find a
distinguished object
and this distinguished object is shared
between
two views that share a substantial
amount of information
so uh because alice and jasmine now
close to each other
there is a good chance that
they will see the same
distinguished objects
while alice and bob which are far away
will not have
clearly will not have the same
the same distinguished object
our third application is to homophilic
secret sharing
this concept was introduced by boyle
gilbanishai
and it is the analogue for morphic
encryption on secret shells
very briefly
hss allows the user to
distribute its input to several servers
in a way that allows the servers to
compute
functions over
the input of the
[Music]
user meanwhile the user can be sure that
his input is
secure as long as at least one of the
servers
is honest
so mongodb thinks hss allows to
outsource every computational task to
to
to compute on remote servers
and it also allows private information
retrieval
one nice feature of hss is that
it gives state-of-the-art communication
efficiency for
several problems
the
hss scheme bgi build
uses a one-dimensional lphs
and in the paper we showed that
if we have a good k dimensional lphs
then
the communication complexity of a
of a
of several hsf schemes
will be
improved by a factor of k
however it trade offs with the
communication
computation complexity of the problem
but anyways
it improve of improves over the
state-of-the-art solution in terms of
communication
okay so after presenting several
applications of lphs let us show how to
construct good such hashings
we start with a basic
construction which is essentially
the statue of liberty
solution we've seen at the start of this
talk
so we define our function h to be the
location location of the longest trick
of zeros inside the the first bits
of our input string
in the example below
the longest trick of zeros inside
alice's input starts at index four hence
we define h of x to be four
similarly h of above the input e3
because the delta starts the longest
trick of zeros
now we see that the shifting property
that the
h of alice's input equals one larger
than h of bob's input also in this case
and this happens because alice and bob
share the same longest streak of zeros
what is the probability that this
property is going to
to hold
so
they read the same stack of zeros
exactly when the stack of zeros does not
lie on one of the ends of the
of the inputs they read
so because the location of the long
streak of zeros is
approximately uniformly distributed we
have that the error probability
is about one over d
so this was one construction of of lphs
let us show another
way to build an lphs
which is based on crystal count card
trick
this is a nice magic trick in this trick
you choose any card you want on the
on the top of the deck of cards
and then you
if if you are at card say four then you
advance
four cards uh
a forward and uh if you then at the card
two you advance i took out
a forward and so on and until you're
stuck and you cannot advance more
because you will go beyond the end of
the deck
because we want our steps to not be too
large we
we take our steps to be modulus 10 so
jack is the one queen is two and killing
it three
so where do you finish
if you
follow this magic trick
so we may want to pause now the
video
so you should finish at
the
card 10.
the reason for this is that with high
probability the roots of all
cards at the toppo will eventually
collide
and
and hence they will get to the same card
eventually
so this is
kind of uh
what we do in lphs we
we want to get a distinguished feature
the
the advantage of this method is that we
do not read the entire set of cards we
we have we only
read a small portion of them
and this is how
we apply
this idea to
to construct lphs
by combining the idea of using argument
and kluskar count algorithm which is
also a polar scandal algorithm we are
able to construct much better lphs we
show that there exists a d delta lphs
with delta smaller than one over d
squared
this is much better than the
argument algorithm which has delta which
is of the order of one over d
moreover we show that
for every d delta lphs we have that
delta is at least one over d square that
is the algorithm and we constructed is
optimal
the proof of the optimality result is
is easy and relies on the birthday
paradox
for the applications we wanted to
generalize our optimal one-dimensional
lphs algorithm to a two-dimensional one
naturally we
wish that we can just
use the same algorithm but in two
dimensions
so luckily argument algorithm works just
fine
however polar scango algorithm does not
have a good analog in two dimensions so
so this construction could not be
achieved
and another idea is just to leverage the
optimal one-dimensional phs and somehow
compose it to a two-dimensional
algorithm
indeed we can recursively apply a
one-dimensional lphs
on columns where each column
the
the bit that is present in in this point
is an lphs on rows
so
the distinguished object is a
is a distinguished column
where in each column we find a
distinguished
object inside that column
indeed this gives a pretty good
two dimensional algorithm
but
it does not give an optimal solution
in this respect one plus one is smaller
than two
in our work we show that
we can construct a better two
dimensional lphs that is delta equals to
one over
d to the power of
seven divided by eight
and also we show a two dimensional phs
which we conjecture to
to get the optimal
trade-off of delta equals to one over d
and and also we we prove that one cannot
improve
the algorithm better than
one over d
now i wanted to present how our
allegedly optimal algorithm looks like
the algorithm starts with a stage of
argument
that is alice and bob start by reading a
squad of data and scout of the
matrix of 8
and find the largest block of zeros
inside it
if they find the same block of zeros
then they
find their shared object and the
algorithm is successful
but if not they proceed to an to the
next stage in which they make a a random
walk
which is similar to the
to the kuskal card trick
but this time they also make negative
steps they may go right or left up or
down
as they
continue their stages increase their
step sizes
and the algorithm is quite similar to
the optimal one-dimensional lphs
however there is
a big difference between these two
algorithms
because
in this two-dimensional algorithm we may
run into cycles
because
we make also negative steps
we overcome this issue by making a
deterministic method to exit the cycles
now while we believe that this method is
enabled to get
an optimal two-dimensional lphs
we do not know how to rigorously analyze
this algorithm so we have two relevant
open problems the first is to prove that
our two-dimensional lphs indeed achieves
the optimal delta of the order of one
over d
and the problem is of course to analyze
the algorithm because of the cycles
and the second problem is to invent an
algorithm which works in io dimension
say in five dimension we do not have any
idea of how to build an lphs
because roughly speaking two random
walks in five
five dimensions may not collide at all